Brian Scalabrine joining us here he's
been on ds/dt show all the time I can't
believe we've never had him on this show
before
from NBC Sports Boston Brian Scalabrine
how are you Brian I knew you were a
minivan guy I also am a minivan guy that
would have definitely came on like a
year or two ago you do have you ever
driven a Honda Odyssey Brian ah the best
I don't understand why like a lot of
these guys with their SUVs and the big
escalators look like that they got it
all wrong it's all about the mini there
with the automatic doors like they don't
have automatic doors that slide the kids
do love those oh my gosh they get in and
out it's it's it's incredible
so where did Rozier come from did you
see anything coming out down here on
three
yeah he's a freak of nature and so
here's like the recipe in the NBA for
success right athletic freak any like
you'll see some of these guys in college
that aren't like this freaky athletic
that no don't do well don't do well with
the next jump
he's extremely long he is extremely
competitive and like the one thing the
hardest thing when you're looking for a
guy is how hard they work but when
you're like you're freaking nature and
you're competitive and you get in the
right environment you're gonna get
better so I don't think that Rozier
takes these steps unless he's a part of
this system you know for three years but
there's no doubt that when you look at
the Celtics and the guys who are coming
through here you know Brad and the
coaching staff and I give the entire
assistant coach the stuff just as much
credit as I give the head coach on this
one in developing guys from Evan Turner
Isiah Thomas Avery Bradley when he was
here to the guys now that are that are
on the roster so that I think Rosie's to
spend a big time joy and the fact that
Kyrie Irving has been out and it's
easier to step up for five or seven
games it's hard to do it over the course
of two or three months has he been
around at all the mentor I've been
around Brian with this project I Kairi
yeah I read the round of every home game
he doesn't travel for whatever reason
you know I'm not really like that no I
don't really care about that kind of
stuff or whether I should or shouldn't
but he's there on the bench supporting
his teammates and
he's not one of those guy that is kind
of like moping that the team is having
success he's like super pumped up about
everybody I think you know being around
LeBron those years in Cleveland has like
really taught him how to be a leader now
whether it's LeBron does some things I
like what he did or LeBron did different
things I don't like right but whatever
it is he's been a great leader to guys
he's always very complimentary even when
he was playing so well and everyone was
talking about the rest of the Celtics
being not that good he was always
complimentary of all the guys loved
Jason Statham a former Duke guys so
Kyrie has been not only just a great
player for the Celtics sistas leadership
that's been second to none so um is he
gonna lie the question is is how much
will he be able to download Brad Stevens
if there's anything to download about
playing LeBron I mean how do you think
that this the fact that you have Kyrie
at your disposal in any way shape or
form did will it matter orders if
Stevens really just have this thing cold
anyway ya know I think it helps
obviously like no one knows a Braun
better than Kyrie but I mean I think
it's really gonna come down to you like
you understand the NBA is it's like the
fine line between winning and losing
everyone thinks it's I'm even you know
like Toronto who we feel all feel like
they got their doors blown off I mean
that line is closer than people realize
but uh the difference between Toronto
and the Celtics I think the Celtics have
four maybe even five guys that they can
throw at LeBron and they've had some
experience like they played against
giannis in the first round they played
against Ben Simmons I get it those guys
aren't the same level but you know the
idea like these freaks of nature 16 that
can handle and LeBron is better than
both of those guys but I think they got
a formula for success and I think
they're gonna make it a you know just
like tough now what is it actually going
to be tough for him you know is it going
to be one of those things where we're
watching the first round and every time
it's like a 50/50 call in the NBA gets
that call or it when he needs to take it
to another level he takes it to another
level or JR Smith it's like three
Giger's like I don't know what those
things are gonna happen but I know the
subjects are going to be prepared to
play him and they're going to have
bodies at him and they're going to be
more like Bogdanovich and bad young as
in
out afraid of LeBron and I thought
Syrian and wilter like at times we look
like Toronto did Brian Scalabrine NBC
Sports Boston also you can listen to him
every weekday morning on Sirius XM NB a
radio channel joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show Brad Stevens does he
deep down sit there wondering how the
hell did I not get a vote for Coach of
the Year based on my peers week though
because not that he didn't get a vote
but I think like anytime you're doing
some type of coach of the Year MVP or
you know whatever whatever it may be I
always think you should give you know
three votes five votes right like five
you should be able to pick more than one
candidate for those coaches to be in
that position to only get one guy
remember it's not the end of the regular
season where you have Philly just won 17
games in a row Toronto has the best
record in the Eastern Conference the
Celtics were 15 and 12
throw it down the stretch right they had
the great start but down yeah now we we
watch the playoffs and all this of all
those votes are in in the regular season
so brass on that and yeah no one else
should be either because based on the
regular season
I'd Wayne Casey deserve that and there's
gonna be a little bit of that like hey
I'm gonna vote for my boy that's just
the way guys are gonna do it there's no
question about that but I just think
like people are overreacting to this
yeah you know I and another thing so
first they should have like three guys
or five guys you should build a vote for
five guys and in second you guys just
look at the regular season end it there
and then let's talk about that and also
the coaches releasing this right now I
think it has to coincide with Dwane
Casey being on the hot seat up in
Toronto he's on the hot seat yeah well
we just voted him coaches year by his
peers so I don't think anybody should be
upset by this it's like a it's a I sound
like a Nolan Boyd point so how do you
handicap the Western Conference Finals
Brian I don't think anybody can beat the
Warriors I kept it when Kevin Durant
went there just messed up everything and
you know more credit to like thinking
all the things that had to happen by
klay Thompson and draymond Green signing
for 17 18 million dollars when they're
probably more like thirty million dollar
player
seth Curry had the ankle it had some
flexibility with Barnes who didn't take
the extension so more credit to them
like that's oh and in the salary cap
jumping you know whatever it was like
thirty million bucks and all that stuff
had to happen for the Warriors to get
you ran and more power to him for
getting up but at the end of the day
like I don't understand how anybody
matches up with them you take two ran
off that team and you start placing him
other places you name a team really we
could say Toronto and I think Toronto
beats Cleveland with Durant if he was
our team we've just Xuan to go to the
NBA final if he was on Houston you say
the same thing but he's on the Warriors
who were already good so I don't see how
anybody has a chance to beat that team I
mean they are so good they share the
ball they play very new age basketball
not a lot of isolations not a lot of
high pick and rolls they're more cuts
off the ball movement and they ship and
then they are they share the ball with
each other to me they're unstoppable at
least for this year but weren't the
Rockets essentially built for this
series I mean daryl morey the general
manager was realized just flat-out
called it an arms race it's an arms race
certainly that Durant stepped up by
going to to Golden State and that this
is it this is the OP this is it they
have they're built for this series to
try and beat Golden State yeah so but
even if they were even if they were and
it even if they had the bodies let's
just say they did like their style of
play with the Chris Paul isolation and
James Harden isolations late in the
clock that's not going to get it done
against the Warriors it's just not
LeBron James is the best isolation
player like arguably the best isolation
player in the NBA gets whatever he wants
in a playoffs and he can't do it so I
don't know how James Harden and Chris
Paul think that they're gonna be able to
do it if you're gonna beat the Warriors
you're gonna have to defend at a high
level and you're gonna have to share the
ball and move bodies and the Rockets do
it through a certain extent with their
initial action but not enough we're late
in the clock you're gonna go ISO on who
you tell me who drank James Harden it's
gonna have the advantages not klay
Thompson on Tremont green it's not Kevin
Durant ieave with dollars he's not gonna
have it he'll have no score but I have a
major advantage over any of those guys
late in the clock and then miss shot
there go the Warriors out and running
moving bodies on the defensive end how
would the Celtics match up well they've
done well against the Warriors because
they guard all that off ball movement
that's what that's why the Phillies
series was so interesting and I was just
guilty as anybody we know like you're
falling into the trap but all the JJ
reddick are the Belinelli cards like all
that off the ball movement stuff the
Celtics a they have unbelievable game
plan discipline where they stay with
guys so that's what the Warriors doing
look at the look at the numbers over the
past four games two seasons and that's
you know with Kevin Durant something
Kevin Durant in playing and some of
those are two and two during that time
but the Warriors do I mean the Celtics
to a really good job of guarding the
Warriors but once you add in Kevin
Durant it just makes it like it's
virtually impossible to me to beat that
team but from a matchup standpoint it
would be a fun series but I do think
ultimately like as much as I want to
pick the Celtics to beat LeBron like if
somebody's got to prove to me that he's
gonna lose and and I don't know if this
is you here that we're gonna do it Brian
great chat we're not gonna lose your
number so we're gonna I'd love to chat
again real soon yeah all right that's
that's what I'm trying to do you got it
all right did you take care bro yeah you
guys Brian Scalabrine the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience